hi guys I'm Greg that John Gill this is
my friend Tony Gil trees e on instagram
follow him there
all this [ __ ] there um we're
doing another episode of day of stoner
reactions this is the fifth episode
restricting oh is that what we're do it
is the fifth episode Tony introduced
into the game injustice I lied on the
last trailer reactions that I played the
game here's the truth
I played the app and I've watched the
entire story mode on YouTube very
similar experience I mean all it does is
not having to go through the more combat
fighting basically now this is gonna
make a bunch of haters go how many times
is this guy lied how many times is guy
dies over a youtuber is always truthful
he's never played a video game in his
life like not maybe I'll work who do you
usually listen what it says anyway
injustice to the lines are redrawn trail
I think this is a story trailer oh I
really did take the story of the first
one I'm excited for this yes good let's
do it
now they got [ __ ] giant armored [ __ ]
yeah Zach Snyder
[Music]
Xavier no water Guardian whoa
vigilante the preservation of life so
often the generation for taking it
chillingly elevating those that keep
guard until they watch too close and the
so-called hero condoning the very act is
what we would condemn to doning the very
act he would condemn transgression of
the past
she action to come
[Music]
and awesome it turns into a stone no
come on
Wow
[Music]
yesterday's law
leads to madness
oh man it's happening in God and becomes
piped the word becomes outcast become
dot
as faction the dark and for
and we'll also find in Slate fault
such folly and if you feel T immigrant
design
Oh give me above my head Oh what's girl
bye - please become blurred
[Music]
perhaps it is time for them to be read
wrong oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you know
[Music]
you know who it is you know that is that
is Zordon Brian Kraft is Laura oh [ __ ]
Oh dark side open this [ __ ] yeah that
was a cool trailer
I thought the villain Brainiac probably
uh yeah I thought that was Brainiac at
the end right you know we'll be we'll
look at the comments see who said it and
then we'll then we'll do a jump cut and
then we make it look like it was more
Brady I get the end because we do that I
thought that was Brainiac I'm pretty
sure that was Brainiac Corey comment
jesus [ __ ] Brainiac it yeah that's
crazy axon is a gaming channel I'm
supposed to know everything gaming
really I didn't comic-book even with
this I mean they always have cool
characters that they bring out of
nowhere like if I could help they bring
my spawn or some [ __ ]
because I don't see that happening they
always have those DLCs where they bring
like that mortal kombat character of
course this is basically Mortal Kombat I
think well we need a static shock we
don't [ __ ] cares about spawn what's who
spawn I mean does he fall out the hole
daddy wanna focus on trash can with
endless yeah yeah yeah and I character
limits there's some Bob characters I
mean we got a wide variety of characters
it's true that that moment when Batman's
look at the screen holder my me of the
Dark Knight yeah I mean I'm exactly the
same in it's not just like I'm just
going to watch it I haven't looked up
the actual plot of this specific
storyline I don't know if it's going to
be them going to another you know
alternate universe to mention man or
whatever it seems like you can seems
like they got the same Superman back
well that was like I mean I feel with
the scene from the last [ __ ] game
where Superman killed Joker because
that's what happens yeah games this look
like there's trying to give you a little
recap and the whole thing but I was
surprising like they were all really
about showing the super suits in the
last one of this one they're all like
yeah we don't have to show that as much
this time
I forgot that Superman killed Joker
that's like the
one of the big plot elements yeah like
graphically so dopey drop you think that
they would actually make like a
full-length movie out of like the way
they put the graphics on this yeah man
like it's just good man I mean they had
that line though about Batman like
saying what you like what someone would
condemn is now he's like condoning
something like that some poetic thing
now intentions but how cool would this
be if in this story
Batman's go into that I've always wanted
to see a story where Batman crosses over
you become major you know what I mean
like like oh he's good but he's always
on the borderline of crossing over and
this in this story you would cross over
I think I'll be really cool Batman guns
of going to bed I never ever happened so
I mean that would be really dope if they
were just like let's just throw this
line in a storyline in this you would be
the best at figuring out the best plot
to actually win yes of course they'll
make it seem like using stoppable
even though yeah immortal man it was
Brainiac coming into the equation I
don't know much about Brainiac honestly
like I the motion of operating actors so
I got a memory of the flat man cartoon
I'm so good with flesh yeah yeah that's
my eye right there really wanted to
bring in one or Supergirl in this one
like it seemed like they really want to
point out that Supergirl than this pay
attention that super girls in this well
yeah dude I feel like it's because the
CW shows are doing so well the generator
they show oh yeah
even when the fight scene where it was a
Batman versus Robin I was like oh that's
interesting because the other one who
was like way I met with hanging over
euros when was that man fighting Robin I
was fighting hero I thought that too but
then I saw the suit was a Rama what yeah
back to them Oh back let's go back to
that moment before I was wrong
that because they look like green arrow
cuz it looks like the photos already
right yeah I don't know they're trying
to be like Oh Robyn's getting that no
turning no Robin Hood yeah [ __ ] three
narrow we're not going to put them in
the redneck Robin green arrow and [ __ ]
they're probably gonna have a lot of
characters from like soup Batman I would
be down to play as a Deathstroke yeah I
mean open
well what's cool about these games like
it seems like they're continuing it like
the end of this looks like [ __ ] the
Man of Steel movie to me is like the
sort of that sequence were like super
don't want to work for that like rural
ground where the buildings it's fought I
like how they set these in like
apocalyptic kind of situations first one
Superman's gone evil and taken over the
world is it and this one I don't think
it looks like brainiacs probably the one
who's like pulling all the strings this
time oh oh man yeah like I said now know
much about Brannock so it's hard for me
to be like this and what this has become
a worthwhile review that definitely dope
about Darkseid has to be a [ __ ] dope
character of course man BBS yeah we're
just right into Batman versus into man
this is a super suits on and flood again
isn't it okay I think would be cool I
think that would be cool tongue cool in
super suits if like right before Wonder
Woman and Supergirl fight a spider web
browsers Wonder Woman shield oh he flips
onto a car spider-man hey everyone hey
that would be [ __ ] amazed that he's
[ __ ] amazing and uh Tom Hollands all
like I'm in this game hello yeah that's
a good Town Hall impression the graphics
look great and I'm really glad and it's
like you can't be it's hard it's hard to
say these days and who you only notice
when graphics really suck these days
because you expect graphics to be
[ __ ] incredible
I'll get my piss when I'm they put out a
trailer that's like has nothing to do
with the game put like that we did see
the gameplay won and so it's interesting
to see just like is this going to be the
storyline like how they're going to go
about it
I know they put a lot of game play out
well already it was easy turning to
Lizzie's for me to watch the story mode
of the first one because I've tried
doing that with games before but I guess
you could sit through like nut because
you know the DC Universe i watch the
injustice like clips and assemble on
youtube
I thought it
was very fascinating I really really
love the story and I'm hoping that the
movie sort of borrow elements from this
injustice storyline
well I all they just keep taking from
Mortal Kombat when more comic comes out
with crazy-ass characters I'm pretty
sure they'll come up with some dopey I
mean it's just taking so long for this
game to come out I'm just like oh I know
they're gonna throw DLCs left and right
of just characters they could add into
the game that's why I'm on Jacqueline
can you imagine go like spawn out of the
Mortal Kombat characters you get someone
awesome like Sonya Blade in there really
go Carrie later horde my shine eh that's
like I mean he could use it lips there's
no nurse let me bring the top of the
food chain you know like it doesn't get
better than those like man I don't even
know any other characters [ __ ] sub-zero
that guy's a such one he again I don't
know he's like a drop below the frost
guy and you like he makes like snowballs
or some [ __ ] like that
that's [ __ ] I'll throw snowballs it
that's my nightmare feel sorry beanie
just like from hell or simple hot but
you know I'm right backfired all good
you know but Johnny K he's an actor yes
you can think I do the split man you do
this blue that you should eras Matic
white and charming you guys know what
the fans want
obviously we're the true fans hmm all
right guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects all of you from any individual
person who watches over the FX Muncie
thank you for watching
Tony is tree Z on Instagram as me he's
an aspiring filmmaker aspiring porn star
making videos every day
of him doing porn yeah and just jerking
off it's primarily so literally this
video I just do it like don't want to go
there will you be hard to my Bilbo